[Music]
thank you very much Vincent I didn't
know it was a technical talk no just
kidding it's going to be a technical
talk and there is actually going to be
some code on the screen even I think and
yes we are going to be talking about
elegant data pipelining with Apache
airflow and we'll dive into some
paradigms of functional programming
actually folk will do that because he
just lost functional programming in
Scala Scala lover but we'll talk about
Python don't worry this would by data
write this so that's what we do to
introduce ourselves to briefly
[ __ ] you might want to sorry yeah so my
name is the four go to this bloom I'm a
data engineer at go data driven what we
do is help the company companies to
become more data-driven so I as a data
engineer health companies setting up the
data infrastructure we also have a lot
of smart data scientists like FinCEN
developer companies build nice
predictive models I'm CEO of House of
banking advanced analytics growing from
55 people now to 320 people in the next
three years so if you would like to join
after this talk talk to me if you don't
want to join it I understand that as
well but that's alright work in the bank
for the ones that do not know what ing
is that's financial services and we'll
actually touch some of the subjects and
maybe you've heard the GDP are things
this is actually where our talks aligns
a little bit and it becomes maybe a bit
interesting there so Apache airflow what
is Apache airflow
well Apache airflow allows you to who
knows Apache airflow by the way oh
that's bigger than the last time who
doesn't know it okay okay that's still
like well 30% doesn't know well Apache
airflow and I have to say incubating
between your bracket because we still
need incubating offer of Apache we're
trying to get out but we sometimes have
a bit of difficulty doing that it's a
task based workflow scheduler we do this
programmatically so I mean you might
have you know you see for
example and I think booking.com actually
uses a sushi still quite extensively is
an xml-based scheduler and Apache
airflow is a python-based schedule so
you create your workflows in Python we
do not really care what you run as your
jobs but the workflow itself is being
created in Python it was developed in
2015 by Airbnb it was brought to Apache
in 2016 and you can use it for ETL
machine learning predictive and general
generic pipelines and it's about it's
used by 120 plus companies including ing
which I work for gala driven spreads it
around but also Airbnb left reddit
people and a lot of other companies are
using it and we have a big amount of
contributors I would say for the 60 plus
and I think our largest the part of our
job for Apache airflow is actually
merging a lot of PR requests instead of
writing a lot of our own code because we
can't keep up under eyes anymore it's
it's the speed by which it's being
developed it's been incredible it's the
downside and the upside of having Python
by the way because that's it's easy
accessible but it's also easy accessible
so than people you know do try to do a
lot of things you might I don't know if
you know but we are fully open source
there are some companies that actually
built on top of an Apache airflow as a
platform Google has released a Google
Cloud composer as a better which is
Apache and airflow underneath and you
can use it as a better now and a storm
astronomer the IO is having it as a
platform you can use that on on a WB AWS
for example or as your if you need it to
it if because no not everybody knew well
actually what Apache airflow is doing
and maybe you don't know how workflows
what workflows how they are visualized
and we talked about directed acyclic
graphs and you see an example of one
behind me or well if you see it on the
screen you don't worry you don't have to
make
what all the older parts are but well
what you need to grasp that they can
become pretty complex this one is not
even too complex I've seen spider that
you know went everywhere and actually
ones that are too difficult for the
visualizer to actually visualize and
then it basically kind of crashes the
scatterer still works fortunately but
the the visualizer it can't handle
anymore that's with thousands of tasks
interestingly here what you need to
remember or what you should stick in
your mind some of the scalars that
you'll see around are about data
scheduling so every bit you will see
here is basically waiting then for data
in this example here and white and this
is where Apache arrow comes in and what
is strong is what it is strong at is
also scheduling tasks so if you see the
the white underneath the white green one
here it says start cluster start cluster
has nothing to do with doing data it
starts up a cluster maybe a nice cluster
or you know you schedule something on
iws or you do something on Prem that's
all fine but it has nothing to do with
you know moving data around it makes
sure that you can start processing data
and that's something different then you
all see if you just move data around for
and you're doing your scheduling based
on data only so why is this important in
um it is well ETL consists of a complex
network of dependencies you've just seen
one basically and it's not just by data
it is also the things that you need to
do around data that come into as come
into this as a penny off as a
dependencies and analytics and batch
processing is still missing critical
although we love streaming nowadays for
for a booking that come for example to
have their air the resource of their a/b
testing arriving late and people would
probably get a bit nervous at the end of
the day for a bank if we do not do our
end of day processing in time you
probably won't receive some of your
payments or you would not have made some
of the payments
real-time pay me paying is still bit
something that's in the future these
things happen at certain points in a day
or in the week even and because of that
even a lot of time or too much time is
being spent on monitoring
troubleshooting jobs we live we live in
the real world and we know that some of
the server's might not be available for
some time and if your our system
requires you to jump on that right away
because it fails at the first time it
can't reach that server then you're
going to be doing a lot of operational
work and you have you're going to have a
lot of people standing standby for this
this is also where Apache airflow helps
you out because it understands things
like during retries and waiting for
later that understands backfill so you
can change history these kind of things
are particularly created for a data
error instead of something that you you
know was maybe some enterprise you
feature for a for a for a for a
particular the company so when we were
talking about you know discussing this
talk what does elegant actually mean and
why is this important when you build
data pipelines well firstly it is about
creating reproducible outcomes and
pipelines so the outcomes that you
create through a pore through a pipeline
need to be deterministic and Foca will
tell you a little bit around this why
well functional programming will help
out in this error area and they need to
be idempotent so when you run either
part of the dag or you run the full deck
again the outcomes need to be the same
so you can't have changing outcomes
that's important they also need to be
future proof so this means that you can
do back filling and back filling we'll
go into that a little bit later allows
you to actually change history because
there're future proof and you need to do
versioning a versioning of your data and
versioning of your code and people
forget very often that you need to
version your
as well you need to be robust against
changes easy changes to deck so that the
world around us changes everyday and
that you will be updating your DAGs
accordingly will definitely happen we
assume that your decks will be slowly
changing so not like on an event-based
change but you still need to be able to
add another task or or remove a task and
change history maybe even accordingly or
just continue in the future with it and
then finally this is maybe what's
becoming more more interesting over
well since GDP our introductions but
also since maturing what understanding
what data engineering is about and what
what happens there is that clarity where
data resides of what it means and where
it flows is actually quite important
it's not just important for example for
the GPR but actually important for your
data science where did that you know
that one transformation happened why did
it happen what did it change and can I
do this again in the future can I do it
do it again in the past actually this is
something that's probably still where
we're looking for best practices I I
take as an example here there a lot of
the with which what Michele at Ford
other four is talking about from Netflix
she's director of data engineering there
and she does really interesting talks
around these kind of subjects is
everything ok oh you know if we make an
impression but no self oak oh yeah thank
you Volken are there any functional
programming and to attest in the room
like some high school people no I don't
do it as well see too academic for me
yeah Scala yeah yeah Skyler's always a
bit dangerous because if you see Scala
people with a strong Yaffa background is
just like alphabets the Scala extensive
yeah
so but I think yeah from the functional
programming and wealth we can learn some
things that will help us write better
and more robust easier pipelines or
elegant as we call it so when we do a
transformation we should look at it as a
function with a defined input and I
defined output and if you have
established this input output we can
determine some kind of contract of
what's operation should do when we have
this it's much easier to test this
operation isolation and we can just test
this behavior with for example expected
input but also an expected input yeah so
when when we look a look at transmission
yeah what do we need to do to make this
yeah to make this search matrix pure and
also to to isolate them from the from
their payment if for example to make
sure that there are no side effects for
example is a top example we see some
global variable some external state that
we pull into the into the function and
increment it then we turn it and yeah
ideally it would something have like in
the bottom one like where you have all
the state internally and just make a
transformation as is so we apply this
transformation to the to the data for
example this is a really simple example
of course but in the real world you
sometimes see that stuff is being
written to files being read with all the
processes and stuff like that yeah I
want to keep this you want to don't want
to change data along with two other
processes you want to keep everything
into one single operation one unit of
work so what's important is the else to
be I deposit in your in your actions so
when you develop something you have to
make sure that the actions that you
write our atom powder for example those
top one it doesn't matter how much you
how many times you execute it the result
will be exactly the same but the bottom
one yeah if you invoke it twice now you
will undo the previous operation again
and this will will result in some
unpredictable behavior so for example if
your task feels in the middle and then
it's hard to determine where you read
stop so when you rerun it
yeah it will be an inconsistent state he
most probably will do some updates and
you'll gather with really weird end
result also this is a really simple
simple example but sometimes when you do
something something like counting yeah
you have to make sure that the counts
that you do are idempotent it's also
really important when writing a Dax and
airflow operations that you take the
date into account like if you have
something that has been run like like a
1 week ago something change you want to
rerun it I want to make sure that you
get the same result so using airflow you
can do templating so for example this is
invoking an HTTP endpoint you will get
some some some currency data from a coin
desk with a set started and set end date
and this will guarantee unless going
desk revises history it will always game
give the same result but in the bad
example when you just get the current
price if you rerun something like a task
that you'd supposed to run like one week
ago yeah we'll just get like the current
price what's also important is being
immutable so you should not see any
delete operations insert operations
absurd operations when you process data
for a specific period of time actually
just overwrite the whole petition so
instead of appending like additional
rows you should fix the logic and rerun
the whole task to just override the
whole and the whole partition so for
example what you end up that that your
sources are have a specific date in
there
and then the whole transformation or the
whole pipeline will keep this date into
account so for example if you have this
is a more like a date arousing example
where you have like some some dimension
tables or some fact tables that you want
to that you want to combine you just
process all the dates that are
that are the same you can also see
easily like if you have something like
this it's easy to paralyze like for
example we process in troops of one day
but it's also easy we can also easily
just yeah I've run multiple days in
parallel because they don't interfere
with each other because there's no
external state and they're not colliding
with each other this is something where
we're heading to like with aho and GDP
our stuff we want to become more aware
where the date data is and what days are
being stored so instead of having all
the metadata inside of your sequel
script I want to have one central store
for example think of something like hi
are you metadata live and you can take
template this inside of your airflow
operations so yeah it makes it easier to
keep track of where the data is being
processed and what a kind of
transformations are being applied to the
data
so when we take this into account it
allows us to rerun the pipelines for
previous days for example at the NP over
I'm currently and we have some some kind
of particle system for user agents so I
want to keep track of okay what kind of
people are using the platform what kind
of devices are they using and we
actually use a user agent parsing of
booking feed comb to do that recently I
think it was updated because of a new
user agent string of the iPhone 10 and
then we update the code and then we say
okay I want to reprocess one month of
data because we didn't know of the
existence of the iPhone 10 by them but
it could be that these strings the data
is in there so we create a new version
of the of the code and we rerun this
code over the past month of the data and
this allows us to just rerun all the
data with iPhone 10 in there then yeah
having this in place is really important
first of all to keep me saying in the
end if you have like like Boca explain
like if you have this big fish like
spaghetti on your screen and something
breaks somewhere and your task it's not
I'd opposed that you don't have any
predictable behavior yeah you it's hard
to be to keep saying and also from a
legal standpoint like okay we have to if
something is there some resulting in the
data now we have to keep you have to we
have to have the ability to back trace
where this comes from
so this is always also very important
that you keep predictable behavior it is
your a slider camera okay here we go
so we're talking a bit like creating
well making sure that what if what's in
your code is actually clear so island
potency reproducibility all these kind
of things what Foucault talked about and
where we use the paradigms of functional
programming for however you need to
apply this to your data as well so we
talked about that partitioning that you
need you have the atom policy also
available within your within your data
but you
also with GDP are involved we like to
like to also know where the
transformation happen and this answer
stuff if you if you talk about clarity
and we talk about clarity by lineage
this answers the following questions for
for for developers but also for their
business users so what is the latest
version of the data that I need so
imagine that you re running parts of
your part of your scripts then is that
if you had a model that was running on a
previous set or a set will generate a
new kind of output because you rerun
history because you created new a new
data from that if that is actually the
case you need to know that because for
example if we as a bank provide you with
mortgage advice you can actually ask us
well how did you come to that decision
and we need to be able to explain it if
we changed history or we're and rerun
the data and we came with a different
output for whatever reason we still need
to be able to go back into the past and
explain you why we made the decision in
the past because obviously in the future
new things might happen and you can do
that but you need to go into the past
and explain why this happened and even
for auditing reasons if it goes really
far very far you need to be able to able
to rerun that model on that old set of
data and see if you indeed came up with
that decision so do you need to save
versus review data yes you absolutely
need to and this can be done by
snapshotting or by features that we're
introducing in 1.10 plus an airflow so
it won't be immediately all there but
some things are popping up and we
actually need your help by code please
or by best practices to understand how
this really works because I don't think
the industry has come to a consensus yet
how do how to do this properly so you
see things according with with the big
companies that they're trying things out
but how to properly do these things it's
still a pretty hard thing to do it also
answers questions where did I get the
data from
and this gets where it's you know it's
not only important for all the reasons
but actually it's interesting for your
data scientists
well because you know if you have a
certain data source where did all the
transfer transformations happen and why
did I get the outcome that I got and
what does it mean do I need to change
that in the beginning to get a different
outcome no no there's something that yo
your data scientist will tell you
eventually and this is where they like
that clarity to go back into your into
your lineage and understand how that
came to be and eventually we need to
store this somewhere and for now that
will be explained us in the context of
Apache Atlas which you might not be
familiar with but this is where you can
store lineage information and from 1.10
there is some basic so in the master and
the master branch of air flow some basic
integration with with Apache air flow or
SRA with Apache Atlas but what is
lineage and I'll put it on the screen
here a little bit and I'll explain how
it works so we have a original data
source called temp whole directory and
from this place we run to batch
operators which correspond to two - an
airflow or airflow operator and this
base operator generates new outputs
which we call contact organization and
cross-references and there's a date
attached to it and then another batch
operator in this case it can be anything
right it could generate a final and
final output I don't know if you support
the problem here because there's a
problem in this diagram because all the
things that [ __ ] talked about they
might not fully apply to the diagram I'm
just showing you here does any one spot
it oh I'll get all explain it without
the small level that screens might be
too small here so a good point good
point we should put bigger screens over
there in the future so you see that the
original file does not have a date
attached to it and the final file
doesn't have that either
so imagine this this was running for two
days because these are their imagining
if I do that for a year then it suddenly
explodes and we get 365 of these kind of
blobs just attach you holder
cheyna final and the final one how do I
get to an idempotent outcome and how the
informer from an original source I can't
because I don't know what's in here and
how to split up according according to
those partitions so to make it elegant
as we talked about there needs to be
some changes to this to make that make
it work so let's build a proper pipeline
and imagine that you are using machine
learning models that need conversion
rate for currencies so the example that
Foucault's just gave you with you know
picking up something from coyness
because we love cryptocurrencies we'd
like to invest them into them but we
also like to have the predictions there
- you know when should I invest when
should I step out just a short example
and you can partially rerun it and you
then use this kind of outcomes for
giving advice to your customers you
should never give a fast investment
advice but in this case for sake of a
sake of the example we'll do it here and
for your business it is important though
that you're able to explain to your
customers how to you how did you get to
a certain decision so versioning is
important and and also going back into
history so bring this together our deck
consists of three tasks it's a pretty
simple one pick up the data run the
model and put the outcomes at the place
where it may make sense we choose the
Apache druid for this because yeah
it was there for fun and the and the the
deck definition is quite simple that's a
start date of two days ago we just ran
it for two days and we build a call it
build currency predictions and it runs
every day this is a chrome tab for the
ones that you know might recognize it is
a daily cron trap it runs at twelve
o'clock for for every day so then we
love to download the currency data and
for the ones that are familiar with air
flow this is a bit of an update that
kind of syntax that you can use
somewhere in the near future I'm not
saying that you can do it right away so
don't try this at home now
because that won't work probably but
we're starting to have this in is that
you define inlets which allow you to set
the execution date and as I spoke of
earlier explained and outlets which in
this case is a is a s3 bucket and you
let this allow allows you to specify the
amount of versions that you'd like to
keep air flow should automatically
determine what version you are at and
then apply the new version and move the
old ones out of the way if it's doing
that and you specify the said that HTTP
operator gets the currency to determine
the inlets and the outlets so this picks
up because you actually we talked about
idempotency part we can run this
independent from anything else we will
pick it up and we'll put it there and
puts it at the right place right away
with a version even then secondly we've
run the machine learning model we say I
assume it's just you know running SPARC
it's pretty simple we have one outlet
because the interesting thing is air
flow is aware of the previous output so
you don't need to specify the inputs
anymore because if you say inlets are
automatic okay sure air flow will pick
those up and use them as input for your
script and the out the outlet in this
case is determined we were looking at
how to do this automatically and obtain
this from spark it's a bit hard and
because they're there the infrastructure
is not really there for it but we can
pick up the pick up the outlet or define
it manually and we call it create
currency predictions and we set the
upstream for this task of course to the
previous task then finally we drop the
table into droid and we do that by table
and you can actually think of the files
already as tables so thinking about that
in the future you could say ok we'll
just have tables with files as a
placeholder where the location is but we
create a druid operator again it has
five max five verses for the invest
predictions table and we create the auto
auto inlets again so it's automatically
determining its make
it easier for you as a developer right
there's not a lot of metadata
programming and it actually helps you to
do it properly and we can write a new
outlet which is their predictions here
and we set your upstream so what does it
get you
so this is the up the one on the top
this is what you'll see for now in air
flow so this is pretty simple this is
just the dag and it has the gap currency
get predictions load into drew it
because that's what we've what we just
talked about right and this is how it
connects this one is the of the create
predictions depend on get currency
loading to do it is grace dependent on
create predictions if we go to applause
however now yep we go to Atlas however
now then you'll see hey I'm picking up
something from coin desk and the name is
not really clear in this case but this
one gets of corresponds to get currency
it outputs is something to earn us free
bucket well it's there you can see
what's doing create predictions
corresponds to the next operator here
trades new s3 bucket and then we end up
and to draw it if you would rather II
run this the next day you would get the
same line so instead of that it explodes
in a graph eventually no you would get
it for the same for Alfred partition you
get the same same line every time that
makes it an elegant pipeline because
that makes it very clear where your diet
data resides and your and it won't get
as complex that you have a difficulty
finding where your duplicate data might
be or these kind of things so concluding
please build pipelines that are
idempotence deterministic have no side
effects and use immutable data sources
and destinations don't do updates
happens or absurd or anything else make
sure that you version your data and make
sure that you version your code
accordingly thank you very much
yes we're hiring you can talk to focal
or me
yes we're competing that is also true
but we like each other
- don't worry all right cheers guys yeah
yeah I think I know where this question
will be going so I'll repeat it I'll
repeat it I'll do that
so you're basically asking how do we
handle packets dependencies if we need
to do item potency yes this was and it
still is a bit of a challenge in the
Python world these kind of dependencies
aren't more difficult to handle however
with the new cube Anita's executor
that's also in 1.10 and you are actually
able to specify the dependencies for a
task now and that will you know that
will with the containers created from
that those will be idempotent so yes
understood that question and there is
well we're getting to a solution yeah
any other questions in the back first
then you know sorry I'm looking a focus
the question and yes it will I mean oh
you will you can no no I'm not I'm not
no sorry sorry I don't I'll repeat the
question sorry sorry guys sorry [ __ ] oh
that was not the so the question was
will Atlas actually be able to handle
the the across different decks the the
lineage across different decks yes
obviously will because basically at loss
itself determines its its lineage
according to the end
the inputs and outputs that are being
created and attached to a certain data
source so in this case and I'm not a
Atlas expert by the way they if you
enter you can integrate with air flow
only but there's a lot of integration
work being done on hive there's a
connector for spark there's connectors
for a lot of other systems nowadays as
well and eventually it will go what they
call open metadata exchange it will
actually allow you to go across
different linear system so they'll do
something if the IDC is an IBM and IBM
component which is more used in
enterprise context so as long as you
reference the right locations for air
flow then it will be able to determine
what the lineage was our core across
tags any other questions oh there was
one here in front yes you did
so maximum versus of output files you
saw that there's a new parameter yep
it's a good question so you're asking
whether you can instead of you know for
the vs. you can use time frames well not
yet actually the max versions right now
doesn't doesn't work yet it's still
something that needs to be implemented
so that's actually a good a good
suggestion
yeah so the idea around so you say that
those files might be overwritten that
could be the case it is actually up to
the developer or to the company to
determine how they want to implement
this so it probably depends on the only
on the company how to do any policies
around it airflow is not going to be
strongly opinionated about it I see yeah
you were first here we go say again we
don't so the question is how do we
handle the different execute to
break-ins and then the data inlets
outlets we don't support different
executors at the same time and so air
foil doesn't do that so I don't fully
understand your question I think in the
end Sparks only a workflow orchestrated
so spark will orchestrate your workflow
keep track of everything get the logs
but in the end for example if you do
with transformation it will be done in
spark so then you will read full bucket
process the spark and then maybe to
clarify it's only metadata that's inside
the inlets on the outlets and there's no
data at all because that won't work
that's not what air flow is for so we're
concluding right
[Applause]
every month